la cible une fois qu' il faut pourrir la
vie des non vacciné sans connaître
qu'ils vivent au quotidien
il peut pas s'attendre à autre chose et
il a tenu ces propos là sur une sur une
émission de grande écoute il a attisé la
haine et après il n'ya faire ça
majorettes meilleur nicher
[Musique]
oui
alors que c'est lui et cadets 15 le shas
pré pandémique est ce que vous répondiez
est ce que je peux vous répondre
président alors je suis pas une
majorette enfin
vous avez un très beau bateau je ne me
plains pas mais ça me fait penser aux
gens qui disent quand tu es jeune fille
s'est fait violer elle avait quatre
femmes m
charest c'est de finir les citoyens
cherché à bien chercher qui parraine
manque donc je tirais thierry encore une
fois c'est pas les insultes qui me gêne
c'est le parallèle avec la collaboration
avec les ghettos avec la ville d'ath et
là c'est ça oui oui ça décrédibilise
tout votre coeur du montage parce que je
suis prêt mais va des heurts avec des
études teinture ya des pour et des
professionnels de santé qui ont été mis
récent indemnités qui ont perdu leurs
proches auraient même plus à me faire du
bien aux gens qui me protégeait secrète
à cause de cette vague ça et on nous
force et bientôt sur est ce qu'on aura
le past and i ter en entreprise ya pas
de tout un tas de gens qui pourront pas
travailler il faut arrêter oui c'est une
dictature sanitaires ou sso 17 ans pour
une maladie sur 8 99 dire une ya dix ans
les vivres on allait vivre
tinamis russe s'est beaucoup à sévir
contre la russie mais vous plaisantez
guillaume moi je trouve qu'on s'arrête
trop sur le sens du mot collabos qui
parle dans ce cas précis et juste une
année aurait songé à arrêter le tabac
mais non
et hop on s'est tu
c'est une insulte gratuite de quelqu'un
qui est dans une grande détresse et
pourquoi ces personnes feront de vous le
vendre détresse tout à l'heure vous
dirigez pas dans une grande détresse
parce que si visiblement pas ce qu'il
peut pour en venir insulter quelqu'un
comme ça c'est comme mtv us mais il l'a
fait très calme alors vous disiez mais
rien n'est même pas discuter alors dit
mireille palombes à et les anti vaccins
vous êtes responsable des personnes qui
ne se font pas vacciner vous vous êtes
responsable en traitant les gens comme
des moins que rien pendant fait que ces
personnels et non vaccinés aujourd'hui
sont traités comme des pestiférés et des
gens sans aucun droit des sociétés mais
si je suis vous avez une portée
médiatique il ya des il ya des centaines
de milliers de personnes mais
aussi à des gens qui sont contre le
vaccin mais les spectateurs que moi chez
miche et estelle
sergio dias vous avez déjà fait beaucoup
de mal regardez pas car
je perdais les médias sont truffés de
gens qui traitent les non vaccinés comme
des moins que rien et le goût salé sait
tous que gilles verdez et fiona bas mais
je ne m'énerve que thierry se sentent au
dessus des partis comme ça comme si on
pouvait rien lui dire
c'est fini c'est fini vous verrez
exactement ça c'est une posture que vous
prenez j ai asséné trois conneries sur
un plateau de télé plus ou moins
regardés et maintenant personnel c'est
pareil mort et la passion j'ai géré mais
vous qu'en pensez vous arrêtez vous
collaborez avec la bien pensante c'est
ça qu'on a dit nicolas arrêté franchir
il se trouve que vous êtes médiocres
sociaux notamment pour un mec qui aime
l'histoire c'est toi des vidéos et
tétouan par l'autre grande personne
sampaio
si anglais
[Applaudissements]